how do you make every bit of you better
and better and better and better over
time then you grow into the ideal
version of yourself on an ongoing basis
because you're expanding into new levels
you see further oh that's where I can go
you expand further wow man look at this
but look where I can go
I've heard you say that you've become
the ideal version of yourself what does
that look like
I mean look the the beauty of the ideal
version of yourself is it continually
evolves as you evolve and the world
evolves around you you know and who I am
today
um I'm like overwhelmed with gratitude
super thankful that I even get to live
this Acumen experience know that I live
almost every day and have an amazing day
almost every day know that I have built
my life into a place where I I
intuitively can begin to feel friction
and then eliminate it where I'm
continually optimizing my today for a
better tomorrow and now understand that
the person I've evolved and grown into
is just the beginning of what's possible
and excited about continually being a
better version of myself on an ongoing
basis till the day I die which is
currently uh one million hours of life
in 114 days and uh 114 years and 54 days
but that is the state but as you can
hear in my energy
growing into your ideal life as you
envisioned it
um is of surreal experience because most
people never actually get to it and then
be get get Beyond it and I've moved
Beyond it right and realizing that it's
actually just this continuous process
that you get to enjoy life while growing
on an ongoing basis what was the
inflection point then from going from a
normal relatively normal guy like most
of the people that are going to be
listening to a person who has this much
more well-defined goal broken down into
steps to achieve that goal what was the
inflection point and what did that
consist of I I was it was a series of
events and a lot of complexity right and
and it was all parts of me right it
wasn't just
um you know a financial situation or a
career situation or a physical injury or
a sickness it was like it was every
single thing to do with my entire being
right and and but specifically it was
sort of this Awakening that I wasn't the
person that I thought I was that I
portrayed myself to be through the lens
of sort of lying to myself of what I was
right and and I say that in the sense if
I really pictured myself as this very
intellectual and very Advanced
entrepreneur and business person because
I had built all these companies and I
had television shows and I was a
professional skateboarder and I had this
multi-platform Universal Brands and
media and I was making millions of
dollars and and so I'm I looked at my
myself as you know to become this you've
got to have some sort of Secret Sauce
you know to even get there and then I
thought that was the fact that you just
boom and bust and work really hard party
really hard like you know like spend a
lot of money lose a lot of money make a
lot of money invest like I thought that
chaos was in fact why I was so
successful you know and and I felt if I
didn't you know work 18 hours straight
for like five days and then go party for
three days and like and then get off
like go on a fitness run and like I just
didn't think I would be able to achieve
the levels that I was able to to achieve
without that in in 2012 I was approached
by
like a big private Equity Group about
doing a 360 deal of everything that I do
essentially owning half of everything
that I do for the rest of my life and
they would invest in my professional
skateboarding League my cartoons my
clothing lines like uh that be part of
my television uh programs everything and
uh when they did the diligence on me
they basically exposed me to me
and essentially showed me how poorly all
of my investments were how bad my
financial management was and ultimately
deemed me as uninvestable and and so for
me I knew like man not only am I
uninvestable
but I'm not happy
like I can't keep doing this I can't
sustain this level of energy hoping that
one thing that I do ends up being the
one big thing that makes me the money
that
um you know then allows me to find
happiness find the relationship all of
that and one one big moment I realized
that I needed uh to change who I was uh
and become the person that I knew I
could become and that that almost if you
can imagine then started the universe to
work right and then then I asked the
question to the universe essentially
like hey I've got to figure this whole
thing out what where should I start and
I just really started looking at
consultants and different people that
could help me on the business side and I
found a book uh called start at the end
which was essentially a business book
that was if you want to create a
business decide exactly what you want
out of it from the very beginning do you
want it to be a three million dollar
business that makes 500 000 in profit
that you live off of every year is it a
business you want to build to 20 million
and sell it for you know three times
revenue for 60 million and how much
Capital do you need build your plan then
backwards to achieve that and it was
just this like mind-blowing sort of like
man that's how I need to approach
business but that's really how I should
approach life
I I need to design the life that I want
how do I want to live what does it look
like where do I live who am I with what
is it what what is money to me in the
first place and and what are all the
things that I really need to be happy
and then start the Journey To Go Achieve
that I started at the end in that era of
of what I wanted my life to look like
not just my business I designed them
both together so that when I found
success in business I would find success
in life at the same time you know
can you remember what you wanted out of
life at that point
yeah you know it was it was I knew I
wanted to be married and have kids right
like I knew I was always meant at this
point if I was 38 30 going on 39 right
so it's like you know older than you you
know what I mean think about that like I
was like in no man's land and and think
about this I had you know made millions
and millions of dollars and was
basically a dead even
I wasn't dead even while they were
saying I was uninvestable it's like man
you basically spend as much as you make
and none of your assets have any values
you'd personally don't even have any
Investments or saved money like it was
this like man you you worked so hard all
these years and you're basically
starting from zero again you know and so
for me I knew I didn't understand money
right and and no sooner did I
like begin to like map out like hey I
want to understand money and it's like
the consistency of of of
income and the ability to create value
in companies and and build and sell them
is something that I really want to learn
like I really connect with the idea of
being able to follow an entire Arc of
creating an idea uh building the idea
and then selling the idea with a
liquidity liquidity goal in the very
beginning this really resonated with me
so I immediately set a strategy of I'm
going to build and sell 30 to 50
companies and own 50 to 70 percent of
them and sell them for between uh 15 and
50 million and do that 30 to 50 times
and make a billion dollars in liquidity
that I figured that out at the very
beginning before I'd ever sold a company
in my life right then I said okay what
am I going to do with that money and I'm
I'm and of course what happens
I'm trying to figure out what money
means to me I got rid of my all my stock
portfolios I got rid of all my assets
and went to cash all the cash that I had
and then
I get a random uh phone call from Tony
Robbins people right and so I just
started dating this girl
um who I was convinced I was meant to
marry who I was trying to convince her
this is our destiny because no sooner do
I feel like I want forever than the
universe provides
um the girl that I believe is that right
and so she's in the personal development
and is really into Tony Robbins Tony
Robbins like reaches out to me and I'm
like oh man I'm gonna impress this girl
so heavily and because Tony Robbins is
reaching out to me now he reached out to
me to help promote his book money Master
the game uh because of my audience at
the time but when I got that book
it changed my life it made me realize
like man I don't even understand money
at all and like I just kept making and
and and spending money and just going
for it but I didn't understand money
then I met a guy through him an advisor
that that I shared my strategy of like
why I would like to create like use my
money to earn money and then he he
walked me into a multi-family investing
so then the stage was set you know
here's here's the girl in my dreams that
I've just got to convince that we're
meant to be together forever and then
I've got my strategy if I'm going to
create Adventure Studio where I build
and sell companies uh you know and make
15 to 30 to 50 million off of them and
do it 30 to 50 times and make a billion
in liquidity then I'm gonna take that
liquidity and I'm gonna invest it into
multi-family real estate that then I
live off the cash flow and then I'm I'm
going to do all of that while rebuilding
my body and getting super healthy and
and now balancing and designing my time
into a rhythm rather than uh and and get
stopped going through this high and low
lifestyle and and use my opportunity in
the TV space to use that Capital to now
invest into strategies for my uh Venture
business that then goes into
um this multi-family strategy and then
do all of that by beginning to you know
balance my time and stop going from
highs and lows and I would build this
Balanced Life and I would be happy
forever
and
boy it was clear it was clear but in the
beginning it's so difficult and there
was points where I didn't know if it was
it was going to happen right and and
then over those first beginning of years
it's why I like to say that like
everything go the cycle of success is
the same for everything in the ideation
stage it's amazing it's going to be
amazing it's brilliant there's so much
energy in it when you launch it you're
so excited I'm launching the machine I'm
gonna invest in all these buildings I'm
gonna this is like you know my wife I'm
gonna get all this going and then
and then what happens when it becomes
real you begin to learn how difficult it
actually is and how much more you have
to learn and what it's actually going to
take to ever get there and this is where
everybody quits right so then in those
first couple years and the companies
that I were building to sell and they
weren't working and and some things were
working not working and and and then
like you know I'm not even getting the
money to deploy it into these buildings
and then like you don't even know then
in 2018 it's like oh like the show may
not come back it's like you know after
after two years of launching it it was
like I don't even know if this is going
to work but then it's my knowledge began
to build I began to expand into life and
then it all began to happen in 2019 and
then boom the entire thing realized and
began to accelerate from that point
forward but but you know back to the
question at hand is I took the time to
get super clear on what that design
looked like and then got better and
better at Living that Life As I Grew
into it and and learned and trial and
error of getting better at at achieving
the goals that I set but I had the
clarity from the very beginning you know
like you do gotta set set the stage for
yourself so you at least know the
direction you want to go and then the
more you understand it along the way you
can evolve into it and adjust it and
gain more clarity and knowledge on how
long it may take you and in some cases
for people
like where you may not even be able to
do it and you may need to adjust course
you know was there a framework that you
followed for working out those goals you
know I I didn't I I think I just wanted
to get incredibly specific right because
I think there's so many different ways
to approach goals but I I always like to
refer to him as Evolution goals right
where okay you were really specific but
now when you say okay I want to build
and sell a company and own 50 to 70
percent and sell it for between a 50 and
100 million and and you know or 15 to uh
you know 70 sell it for 50 to 100
million now now in lies the complication
in that what you don't know is like okay
well then you've got to co-fine that
business you can't invest in a business
that's at a later stage at a five
million seven million valuation and
never get that type of return right then
if you co-found a business and now you
have founder shares and now you want to
invest
um you know a few hundred thousand into
it now you got to be raise Capital now
you got to be careful of dilution right
so if the company doesn't work now you
started out with 30 that if it sold for
100 million you get 30 million but by
the time it creates the value to be sold
for 100 million it's raised so much
money uh you now get
500 Grand you get like barely a return
on your money it's like all these things
I had to even learn on like like hey
there's a lot more X factors in this and
and okay you did all this research and
built a great strategy for an
opportunity then the market turns on you
like oh the research was worthless like
once you got to Market there's all of
these things that are so unpredictable
that are part of any process that's
that's sort of the idea of like when you
choose Venture creation because you
gotta understand I set my life goal
of creating a billion dollars in
liquidity and I had never sold a company
in my life I've just decided like hey
I'm gonna this is what I'm gonna do you
know and it wasn't until I sold the
first one where I was like man
I can really do this you know what I
mean and then like and then when the
second one the third one then when you
sell one and make 130 million dollars
off of one then it changes you and then
you're like wow okay that actually is
way more fun than trying to sell uh
trying to get 30 million right like it
you just continue to evolve as you build
the confidence and the understanding in
this but it started with the clarity of
what was possible then I continued to
evolve and learn deeply learn on what I
needed to do to continually adjust in
order to find the success that I was
able to find in a pretty short amount of
time you know so if you've got that as
the grand goal what is the story or the
framework of how you've come to think
about time in life
yeah and look and I think what what had
sort of uh transpired along the way is
as I was like really learning how to
like build operation the operational
side of a business I was introduced to
this concept of the rhythm of company
and it was basically the year-long
Cadence of how the company would operate
right there's a certain amount of
financial meetings marketing meetings
brand meetings product meetings
um all this stuff went into sort of a
weekly Rhythm that included Christmas
parties and holidays and vacations and
weekends and and I'm like man this is
forget rhythm of company I I want to
plan all this stuff into my company but
I want them to integrate my life into
this I want the rhythm of existence so I
took the same group that that helped me
build the rhythm of company and they
built me the rhythm of existence which
essentially became the operating uh
system for my life and so what naturally
occurred there is you begin to design
your time for the whole year right
because you know when birthdays are and
holidays are and you begin to look out
or when when do I want to have vacation
and this and this and that so you begin
to see time as a canvas where it's like
okay you're this is what you want to do
the entire time this is how much time
you actually get to do it and then over
the years I just went from you know
being more intentional with my uh
planning of time but then seeing well
you need a ton of adaptability in there
based off of how you're feeling and how
things are changing right because you
never want to be rigid with time design
you want to use time design as the basis
of your discipline but you don't want to
be
um like controlled by your calendar you
still need like to to adjust your time
design based off of how you feel which
sometimes means blowing a whole day out
and just spending the day with your wife
in order to just recover and regroup and
and fight for another day right in in
over time then I began to okay well
shoot let me just start filling in the
gaps and logging what I did the previous
day so that I can begin to understand
where I'm using time then I hired
somebody to write a script and pull all
that data and put it into a dashboard
and it was like mind-numbing because
it's like for the first time now you see
exactly where you spent all of your time
for a week and for a month and for a
year and it became so insightful of
beginning to understand like where you
actually enjoy life the most and where
the rhythm of life feels the best and
you begin to see where time is wasted
and where you actually have a lot more
time
um to spend with your wife and your
family that the amount of time that
you're dedicating to meetings and work
isn't as necessary as you think they are
and you can begin to optimize those and
and it was sort of you know again
something that I grew into over time uh
and got better and better at to where
now it's like man I I'm you know since I
look at it in time and percentages of
like an hour a day is four percent of
your life and you begin to look at you
see the world through that lens
uh you just you you you understand the
value of time so specifically that you
when you think about planning something
you think about the first second and
third order consequences of taking on a
project not about like what it's going
to take uh to get it off the ground but
how many hours is it going to take and
then how long is it going to take those
hours and ultimately it's why I I push
to drive everything uh to automation or
ultimately the least amount of time that
I dedicate to it uh to never allow
myself to be overwhelmed by the things
that I choose to do is another process
of of sort of time Mastery but it's
something you've got to again
start with intent and then get better
and better at it over time in order to
ultimately even know how to optimize it
in the first place you know what are
some of the most extreme ways that
you've become efficient or effective
with the way that you spend your time
you know I like you know when you say
extreme like
um
you know
perhaps yeah it's it's it's funny like
I'm you know the latest thing that I've
really done is I've broken down all of
my income you know into how much money I
am making per hour post tax dollar
right so I I shoot 336 episodes of
Television a year it's four percent of
my time right see and so how does that
happen well that happens by you know
driving automation into your entire
production team your entire development
team your writing teams and every single
part of your company to where you've
optimized shooting to where now you can
shoot a 22 minute episode and 25 minutes
with 10 minutes of prep right and then
you can block those and shoot four times
a month and get Eight Episodes done in
five hours right that's how I was able
to do it in a very extreme way but I
then back that out and then well that's
ordinary income that I've got to pay
these fees against and then pay a full
boat of 50 tax so I still take those
hours and run those hours into like how
much did I make post tax per hour then
when I look at my Venture business and
how much time that I spend there okay
now I make a significant amount of
income that's more in a long-term
capital gains and then I run that by our
land that's that number's not as nice
because I'm putting a lot of work uh
into those companies and that effort's a
lot more extreme versus when you look at
my passive income assets and the amount
of money they generate and then you put
that per hour on a tax basis you know
it's like 20 times anything else that I
do right and so as it relates to now
being able to take your understanding of
time to the way that you spend it to
earn money and then to for that to make
real sense all of that is only 22
percent of my time in a nine to five job
is 27 of your time right that's how
little I work right to manage all of my
assets to build all the companies and
shoot television podcasts all of it
everything that I do as it relates to
um everything with my work side is about
you know you know some some months it's
like 25 26 but on average it's around 22
you know and and that's that's to show
the the scale of what I'm able to
accomplish with the minimum amount of
hours each day because I've just gotten
every aspect of it so automated and
efficient right and and then you look at
every bit of your life through the lens
of automation how can I create a system
for it or how can I automate it to drive
it to energy neutral so I don't have to
think about it or dedicate dedicate mind
share to it and and that's everything
from meal delivery to you know
supplement subscriptions to the way that
I my my the you know my chief of staff
and my assistants like manage every
single aspect of of my my calendar and
my time and my life and and all aspects
of my how how uh of my house and how I
travel all of these things are built
around saving time and energy and have
protocols and systems so I don't ever
have to think about it again you know so
that I can leave and go spend an hour in
the afternoon picking up both my kids
from school uh before I have one more
meeting before I take my wife uh to to
the movies that night right like I'm
really prioritizing living a harmonious
life in a fully balanced existence on an
ongoing basis and the only way that that
really can happen is if you drive
um everything that's complex to a more
simple automated State otherwise I would
just be overwhelmed all the time and
continually needing to like oh let's
Okay what do we go what am I going to
eat right now oh what am I gonna like
okay what do I got to do to try to like
like figure out a hotel or travel or
whatever it may be all of these things
that that you think about that take mind
share I've just eliminated you know when
it comes to getting tactical what were
the most important first steps that you
took when building this system who were
the first hires who were the most
important hires that you brought on
board here's the thing about like
everybody in their own personal system
right it's it's the you know when it
comes to hiring not everybody can hire
an assistant but you better believe
that's the number one uh hire that
anybody's going to make right and it's
it's your and you can call it whatever
you want you know but you're trying now
to invest in a body that's essentially
now taking care of things that gives you
back time and energy right and in in for
the beginning stage of people that's
like helping with uh errands and and all
these sort of mundane things that that
happen on an ongoing basis there's a
water leak in your apartment your house
whatever it is it's like these
unexpected things that continually still
time and mind share is sort of what that
um that type of hire can really do and
and again it will be how efficient they
are going to be for you is the way that
you design what they do for you
you know and the more systems that you
can create for them that you know is
going is going to make them more
consistent for you is than going to make
sure that you're not now working to give
them work well it's an example of a good
system
you know I think I think for me it's
like I'm I keep a live document between
me and my assistant and then we every
single day all everything that I want to
talk about the following morning we meet
every single morning that I will then
list out everything inside that document
throughout the day that I want to
discuss the following day and then in
the morning we meet every single morning
and then go through all of that then go
through the entire calendar and
everything that needs to to be adjusted
or be added to the calendar and calendar
to make sure that all of that is in
order
um we go through all of the the on the
the emails I haven't responded yet
together to make sure that I go through
and knock that out first thing in the
morning uh you know all the data that I
collect making sure that like hey I
collected all the data uh did I ask my
wife how she feels about our
relationship that I add into my
qualitative data like everything
collected like it's it's almost like
like you know all of these different
aspects
um that are important on keeping me
disciplined and in my rhythm I've added
to our system that we do every single
day except for the weekends in order to
to to continually to keep the whole
thing flowing you know
I've heard you say that you're at Peak
top now yeah yeah
what have been the longest levers what
have been the biggest changes the
biggest step changes you've seen was it
quitting alcohol was it brain training
what was it
look and think about it more from this
this lens right and I'll ask you like
how disciplined are you versus how
disciplined do you think you can be in
in your daily life today I've got a lot
of Headroom to fill okay right so so
it's like and then do you go in
discipline streaks like where it's like
okay I'm in the gym five days a week
okay and then I've been eating uh I fell
off for like a little bit like I mean
usually yeah that would be right yeah
you know what I'm saying so so if even
the most successful driven disciplined
people
it kind of live in a rhythm a feast and
fathom Rhythm right and for me by
beginning to track my discipline on an
ongoing basis like and deciding like you
know this is my core seven uh did I get
up at five did I brain train did I
meditate did I get in the gym did I eat
clean uh did I not drink and did I take
supplements right by tracking that every
day that began to at least gamify and
put a number to how disciplined I was
um and and so over the years I would
just you know I would I would get more
and more disciplined over time and it
was so clear in the data right at least
especially from the qualitative
standpoint right because I also track
how I feel about my life work and health
zero to ten every single day so I have
this qualitative measurement of the
quality of my life right then I have
sleep scores with the aura ring and a
Readiness score and then I have my body
composition position so I have this core
set of data that's you know basically
collected together is my quality of life
so I've gamified it and now I have
Insight uh to how I'm really feeling
right and I know over the over the years
that I'm getting healthier and happier
right and if you tie that to money I'm
getting healthier happier and wealthier
right and so seeing all of it work
together and continually
um learning and growing you finally get
to a point
like and that that's kind of why I refer
to it as Peak top is it's the as I was
trying to figure out a way to describe
the psychological feeling of like when
you finally like hit a place where like
a permanent change happens in you and
it's similar to rock bottom right where
it's like when you finally like you've
it doesn't matter how many times that
you tried to quit like like you finally
something psychologically shifts in you
where like you're drug free for the rest
of your life right and from some rock
bottom moment but the difference was it
was on the other side for me where I
kept getting more and more disciplined
where finally one day it was like
why would I just never not feel amazing
for the rest of my life
and then from that point forward I have
never once missed one day of doing any
of those of brain training meditating
getting up at five eating clean not
drinking uh having supplements like
getting in the gym like I it like not
once in in so to me when you transition
to that level of commitment where you
are just a hundred percent and then like
the quality of my life this like the
depth of my thinking the the complete
transition and evolution of who I've
become over the last six months of
finally getting to that level was only
possible
by slowly getting more and more
disciplined over years and then being
able to quantify both how disciplined I
was in a percentage and then how that
percentage affect my actual quality of
life and qualitative data if I wasn't
seeing that data and I wasn't getting
the proof that I was actually the more
disciplined I would get the happier I
would become and then getting more
disciplined and happier over time gave
me finally drove me to the point where I
was
you know like just landed in a place of
why would you ever
want to not feel like amazing every
single day and that's a difficult place
to get to because now it's like I can't
even fathom if I'll ever eat sugar or a
snack ever again I can't even fathom if
I'll ever have a drink ever again I
can't it doesn't even make sense to me
six months in you need to have that
relationship between discipline and felt
sense though because without that the
reinforcement mechanism for the
discipline is always going to be
fighting a losing battle because right
now it's always going to be easier to be
undisciplined unless you can somehow
front load the feeling of benefit that
you're going to get in future so that is
the correlation between the qualitative
sense related to the discipline that you
have and then when it comes to it's full
55 in the morning and the alarm goes off
you think [__] why should I get up well
the reason that I should get up is
because I know that if I don't get up
I'm going to feel this much worse why
shouldn't I eat sugar I know that if I
eat sugar I'm going to build this much
worse this is why I should train this is
why I should do all the rest of it so I
think
I spoke to Ryan holiday about his new
book which is discipline his Destiny
last year and without a goal there is
nothing that you can measure your
discipline up against right if you don't
have something that you're aiming for
there is always a justification to not
go and do the thing but in terms of
motivation to do the thing or
reinforcement to do the thing you also
need a backwards or an internal looking
like the goal is the forward and
external looking and the internal
looking is how does this discipline make
me feel and how can I front load that
from the future which will be better to
the now to offset the discomfort of
doing the hard thing
this is right but here's the thing
you're missing
I'm not disciplined anymore
right this is just how I live I can't
even I don't even try I don't think
about it I don't even no part do I ever
think like oh I shouldn't be doing this
it's the opposite if I can't do these
things I'll I'll move my schedule around
I'm not going to go a day without doing
it you know what I mean it's the it's
the it it goes from uh it's you got to
get disciplined right and create all
these devices and ways and motivations
in order to actually do it then that's
got to become a habit that reduces the
effort and then once it becomes
intuitive or a way of being that's when
everything really changes right that's
when you're no longer even like it's the
opposite where before you had to get
yourself to do it now now you would be
like you can't even fathom not you'd
have to get yourself to not do it yeah
exactly
which is a very difficult place to get
to you know I've got it in my head that
it's almost like
we struggle to work out
what life is going to be like over a
longer time Horizon and especially if
you're doing something now morning ice
bath getting up on time not eating sugar
doing whatever it's difficult and the
reason that it's difficult is because
there is a huge activation energy for
you to start rolling that ball up the
hill but if we were able to see
investment in discipline as almost like
paying into or maybe stepping on some
sort of a seesaw that over time it's not
going to move it's not going to move and
you're just piling up little rocks and
little rocks and little rocks then every
so often it's going to start to even out
and then before you know it look the
discipline is an investment in the
future where discipline will no longer
be needed and I think that's a really
nice way to reframe it that's it that's
it and I think you know
um discipline is Destiny is pure in its
and it's like one of the most beautiful
statements there is right but the
problem is discipline is is a difficult
word discipline means hard it means not
what you want to do it's like doing what
you don't you don't like feel like doing
but you know you gotta do there's just
all it's just this like har harsh and
it's like like you want to know that you
just have to be disciplined in and at
the core of it what is discipline
discipline is just being intentional
right like it's just being intentional
and and you want to get it to a place
where it's no longer even something you
even consider you know and and but but
how do you do that without having some
sort of frame of reference and I didn't
have a goal I understood through the
data this is when you feel the best this
is when your body has the best
composition this is when you are the
lightest this is when you're the
happiest you're sharper you're deeper
like you're you're more present right
you don't uh find yourself drifting into
uh dwelling in the past or worrying
about the future you're you're living in
the present and you're creating a better
future or rectifying the past you're
always living in a state of action and
experience like when when you think
about all of these payoffs from a
qualitative standpoint that are hard to
see and feel when you're just being
pulled from all of these different
directions on an ongoing basis trying to
make one part of your life disciplined
when the truth is you've got to make all
of your life difficult you've got to
make all of your life disciplined to
make any of it disciplined we just for
some reason think that we can pick
isolated things to work on or improve
and that our lives will be better when
every single part of us every thought
every action everything we do integrates
together to make the whole and we have
got to design the whole with intention
and live the whole with discipline for
anything to turn in to an intuitive way
of being you know how do you avoid
catastrophic thinking if you fall off if
that's the case if everything is
interlinked and one small error has a
cascading effect across the entire
Global world that is you how do you
avoid small errors becoming big errors
well well I think the the construct and
the framework that you present no longer
exists right everything is integrated
but not one thing can disrupt the whole
right when you have Harmony in the hole
these these disruptions are hardly felt
right and then they're they're so
isolated and and you just immediately
take action on that friction and
eliminate it and get back into harmony
when you're when you're operating from a
harmonious State and continually
evolving expanding into a better version
of yourself you're now looking out into
the future and predicting the the future
outcomes with a much more consistency
but you can also see
potential trouble down the road that you
can avoid and then when you get hit with
the unexpected you're not being hit from
a place of balance where the
catastrophic thinking comes from is when
you're teetering on all these edges and
finally it's the straw that breaks the
camel's back and collapses because think
about it when you feel catastrophic it's
when your mind collapses right because
we're never doing too much unless we
feel overwhelmed and then the moment we
feel overwhelmed it's our mind's way of
basically going into like full fight
mode where it's like overreact you've
got to stop doing this stop doing this
stop doing your mind's trying to get
back to this level State when it gets
overwhelmed and most of the time we're
going from like we're balancing all of
these things trying to improve different
things and get this and I'm I'm working
on this deal to get this and then when
when one thing's collapse they all
collapse in at once and then we question
everything
then we're like should have never moved
to Austin should have never moved to
Austin it's like it's like I I really
discovered that my mind lived in this
range of neutral and I could take it or
leave it like didn't feel overly
positive but wasn't negative half full
which if half full man I could get hit
by something but I'm still believing in
the future and what it's going to be or
half empty and half empty when I when I
felt half empty I could pick apart
anything your decision making doesn't
make sense you wish you wouldn't have
bought a couch you know you like oh why
did I why did I even invest in that like
five years ago like your mind like is
trying to find back to that place of
order and it's very difficult if there's
not intention in the hole and balance in
the hole to be in a Perpetual state of
of having a balanced mind because we
just compartmentalize and and have too
many too many things that if one one or
two go wrong the whole thing collapses
and that's what I learned over the years
through the process of of using that
qualitative data and developing that
qualitative self-awareness that here are
the things that overwhelm you here's
when you're over capacity and you get
overwhelmed so that makes you think even
further when you take on something new
how much capacity does my mind have and
if I take on something new what risk do
I have that that's going to be the one
the one too many thing that begins to
overwhelm me in my flow you know have
you ever considered opening up your API
or whatever this system is for other
people to use
yet no I'm developing an entire like
super intuitive way for people to apply
exactly what I do and sort of you know
guide them on how to grow into it right
because it's not something that like you
can uh do overnight the first a bit of
discipline you've got to develop is
logging the data you know what I mean
the first thing you got to do is be
begin to like believe that like putting
in the qualitative data and asking
yourself how you feel zero to ten about
your work your life your health whatever
you want to be that qualitative marker
of your quality of life the first step
is collecting that data how right and
effortful is that for you how long does
it take per day how much does it feel
like homework how much did it feel like
homework when you first started you know
I I don't I don't know that it ever felt
like homework and it really changed for
me when I could see it in a dashboard
man when you when you can see how where
you spent your time that day and then
like how you felt about that day and how
and all how disciplined you were that
day that week that month it gets
exciting right and you become motivated
and it's you know it takes a few minutes
in the morning to do it it's really
really effortless it's when you get
overwhelmed and you got a lot going on
and then you you sleep late but you got
to get to these emails it's the like
like you know the idea of Life uh we we
tend to
you know live life on this pace of uh
never getting to do the things that we
want to do because we're always doing
the things we have to do and and that's
sort of that idea of time design when
you begin to time block and like hey I'm
always gonna get up and do these things
and then I'm always going to work out at
this time because I know that's where
I'm going to be more consistent like I'm
going to brain train and meditate here
because I know I'm going to be more
consistent like when you begin to do it
that way then then it becomes more part
of your Rhythm and you've designed it
around
your ability for it to become consistent
right like and and for me that's just
um where it went from hey I gotta get
the data to like no instead of getting
up at six I'll get up at five so I have
time to log the data get the email in
there meditate and brain train before
um I start my day at six o'clock you
know I'm interested by this brain
training it's the one thing out of your
course seven that I if you said in
advance what do you think is going to be
in there that I probably wouldn't have
predicted what what what is the process
you've evidently looked at the data and
seen that when you do it you feel better
so from a felt sense it must be
effective yeah look I I think even
um
from
from a what it's doing for my brain I
have zero data
what it's even doing to me I have zero
data what I liked about it was I don't
necessarily need the science behind it
to know that I want some cognitive work
in the morning right so it's a super
simple sort of like series of games each
day right so
um it was the hardest thing to stay
disciplined at right like for some
because it was like okay you gotta now
Focus right and for me who's like oh let
me just work on stuff I love creating
stuff and what you know like whatever
whatever and so
um it was in the first couple years the
one that had the lowest percentage and
now
now that I do it every single day this
year I use it as a gauge to how sharp my
mind is working every day so now I
qualitatively rate how well I brain
trained how sharp I felt and it's
fascinating because like man sleep eight
hours get a 95 sleep score you know
obviously I'm not drinking not eating
sugar like intermittent fasting like I'm
just as like lean and mean as you can be
like you know every last thing highly
balanced beautiful existence super happy
like everything but like I will get a 95
sleep store and get up and brain train
and my brain is just barely firing I
just can't even let's like you know I
would give it like a four and then some
days I'll you know sleep six and a half
hours and get up at 3 30 in the morning
and and then I'll be like boom firing it
like a nine I have not been able to find
a correlation in all my data on what is
keeping my what will be a a reason that
my mind will fire sharper yet and and
it's super fascinating because I been
experimenting with all types of stuff
like drinking salt water and doing red
light therapy when I first get up to see
like okay what will light on the eyes
and salt water uh do to like brain
function in the morning and I mean
nothing like I have not been able to lie
like and here's the beauty of like being
so highly optimized and so disciplined
you can you can bring things in and out
and see how they feel you know you have
a control right everything is going to
stay the same yeah it's like you're so
consistent that you can introduce things
and and really understand their effect
you know especially in diet and then the
other thing that's really amazing for me
since I I bet since I shoot like the the
five hour block of shooting Eight
Episodes back to back to back to back
like that's this thing that really tests
like my stamina and my sharpness for big
long periods especially as it relates to
um uh the type of sleep that I need what
I eat and when I eat uh throughout the
day to to be as sharp as possible it's
another Super interesting gauge that I
have introducing nootropics into that to
see how they affect it like all
different types of stuff is really
fascinating but that's that's one of the
the joys of of sitting at that level
is then everything you introduce like
you don't have to there's so much
variability in stuff that you could
choose to do to optimize uh all aspects
of your life and the problem is when
you're when even when you're slightly
inconsistent with diet or sleep or
alcohol or anything you put in your body
stress that you may have like all of
these things that would ever disrupt
your Rhythm are going to give you
misreads in that personal data to
understand if this really is making an
effect and has a quality a quality on on
you you know and that that's something
that that's really amazing that I get to
have for the rest of my life you know
because it's like you just keep getting
healthier and healthier and you keep in
now like in I don't just like
um work out I work out and test every
muscle in the body to make sure no
muscles in the body ever fire hypertonic
right so it's like and build any
compensation patterns right because I
had to basically unwind an entire
dysfunctional uh muscle and skeletal
structure from uh having a a
um you know essentially a a weak upper
trap muscle when I was a kid that led to
a hypertonic uh PEC minor that led to a
hypertonic ql and a glute me that got a
colonial nerve that destabilized my
ankle and then I built this professional
skateboarding and athletic structure on
that for for 35 years and then had to go
through the process of learning
everything about my body including
eventually learning how to test every
muscle soul and how it's firing to then
reprogram my neurology so that my entire
skeletal and muscle structure fires
flawlessly
to take you on a rabbit hole of like how
deep even how I look at the human
functionality and how easy it is to even
get yourself into a position of being
disciplined with diet when you spent all
the years to learn all the muscles of
your body and got your body to fire
correctly and now really see a pathway
to living healthy and stronger deep into
your hundreds you know in a very healthy
and happy way you get even more
motivated as all you keep adding all of
this depth to your overall being you get
more motivated to be happier to learn
more to do more but it's in all aspects
of my life it's my relationship with my
wife my the way that I treat my body and
my health the way that I understand
money and my finances the way that I
build companies all of it together is
how do you make all every bit of you
better and better and better and better
over time then you grow into the ideal
version of yourself on an ongoing basis
because you're expanding into new levels
you see further oh that's where I can go
you expand further wow man look at this
but look where I can go that is what I
realized is the actual output of this
deeply intentional holistically designed
uh being and and creating sort of
milestones and measurements to all of it
and then just getting better and better
at being a human over time you realize
the actual Joy of life is living in a
balanced harmonious State and
continually and perpetually evolving
into your Limitless potential that's
actually the joy of life and it's like a
dopamine drip because you get so excited
about man what the future is going to be
then you pass a milestone then you
celebrate that for the day of like wow
that's amazing but look at what the
future is going to be it's this
continual uh dopamine experience that's
generated through yourself on an ongoing
basis you know you mentioned your wife a
couple of times today you're married to
a Playboy model who won Queen of the
Earth or something Queen of the world
queen of the world this is Mrs Queen of
the world I could cry thinking about it
again Mrs Queen of the world what's the
story of how you started dating her
yeah I mean look you know I'm for me it
was
you know I had you know in that
beginning moment of like really living
with intention and I decided like okay I
I am someone that believes they are
meant to be with someone forever build a
family
um and so for me I truly
like
um decided what I needed to do is change
who I was but in this era
you know like I decided like you have to
become the person
that uh the person you want to be with
forever will will respect and be with
who become the person that they would
want to be with essentially and then man
and then I went on like a journey of
absolutely like like not hooking up with
chicks telling all my friends like hey
like I'm just waiting I'm just waiting
when I
um
when when she appears I'm Gonna Be Ready
like I'm gonna be able to tell her I've
been waiting haven't hooked up with
anybody like waiting and I'm at the nine
month Mark like
I'm
like saw her Playboy uh thing and was
like this is my wife right and of course
you're saying well of course you know
you know like everybody says that when
they they see uh you know they see this
beautiful stunning girl in in and uh
play but they're like oh of course right
so I was immediately this is my wife
right and when I pictured like okay this
is perfection from a beauty standpoint
but she had this interview where she
talked about
um she wanted to swim with sharks she
wanted to pet a tiger
and um I thought to myself well shoot
I've been attacked by both of those
um this this right here this is Destiny
right so
I DM her right and we start uh talking
in DM and I say hey you know I think I
could be a great life coach for you uh
because you want to
um swim with sharks and pet a tiger I've
actually been attacked by both of them
on purpose and so we we begin to talk
and you know I'm already I haven't even
talked on the phone we're just now moved
to text and
and so I'm already convinced like this
is my wife like I I did it like I I
changed myself I look I changed myself
um like I was patient and now nine
months later we are here right let all
my friends know I met her at work the
universe provided
um later that week okay we're just
texting she tweets about Dayton Ohio
right and I'm like who why did you tweet
about Dayton Ohio she's like oh my my
brother and mother lived there right now
of course Dayton Ohio is where I was
born and raised and my whole family
lives right so now I'm like what her
mother and brother live in Dayton Ohio
this is my wife okay and so still
haven't even spoke still have never even
spoke on the phone this is just over
text and
um so we decide like okay let's let's uh
get together so you to get together on
Friday she's like sure what do you want
to do I got to be impressive this is my
wife I gotta take it to another level
she had just tweeted
um you know about this kennel that was
essentially shutting down and they were
you know getting all the puppies away
and all the puppies that that people
didn't adopt would end up like getting
euthanized potentially right and so I I
said you know so my idea was like hey
let's go and look at some puppies as a
first date right is sort of what I
wanted to do but it turns out that was
two and a half hours away
and I'm like oh man we can't drive to go
do that so as a joke I said what do you
think about grabbing a helicopter and
flying out to the kennel and rescuing
some puppies and
like a half hour later she's like great
and I'm like what and so I had to go
figure out sort through and get a
helicopter still never spoke to her on
the phone
and so I'm
I was convinced now okay this is my wife
and and for some reason or for the last
15 years every person that I like was
sort of connected with always had a
connection to Hawaii
and so I was convinced I was meant to
marry somebody with a connection to
Hawaii
and so as I was driving to pick her up
hoping that this was an episode of
Catfish since we never facetimed never
even talked on the phone nothing
um I kept telling myself forget about
Hawaii
forget about Hawaii why do you care like
she's she's gorgeous like you know her
parents are from Ohio like this is meant
to be uh picked her up it wasn't a
catfish she got in the car first
question I asked do you have any
connection to Hawaii and she's like
well
uh you know my grandmother lives there
uh right now my sister lives there with
her and I'm like
perfect this is my wife right so now I'm
like I mean I don't even I don't I'm
like you know it's not like the Deep
connection I had hoped for but good
enough and so we take off we go and get
in this helicopter and we're flying
across California on our way to rescue
some puppies and we just start talking
you know I'm trying to be impressive and
like you know but also like you know I'm
like you know I got my stuff together
you know I've really been working on
myself to like really you know you know
whatever just trying to you know like
not blow it you know what I mean but you
know be cool but not too cool and
she begins to tell me her background her
story and you know we're just talking
and then she shares with me
um that she was a Make-a-Wish child that
she had a rare blood disease when she
was 10 years old and was given six
months to live
and so make a wish granted her a wish
and her final wish was to swim with
dolphins and make a wish granted her
wish and flew her to Hawaii where she
swam with dolphins and when she
um
swam with those Dolphins she told
herself I'm not going to let myself die
like I want to experience stuff like
this for the rest of my life they went
back they offered her an experimental
treatment which ended up putting her in
remission and curing her
indefinitely right and so for me right
then then I was like whoa this is my
wife you know and so as incredible and
beautiful as that is right you know got
all the makings of it a storybook and an
episode of Bachelor all in one
the reality of our relationship and what
she gave me is so beyond
so beyond just that magical story
because
what we became and what she gave me was
forever she my shifted from looking at
like what was next and how do I build
this business in life but like what does
Forever look like because now I really
see like who I'm going to build a life
with and why I want to realize my
potential to realize it for us and like
want to have a family with and that
became the anchor of what really allowed
me to begin to evolve and and and find
the success that I was able to to find
and I I have never once you know in this
you know 10 years and eight years of
marriage even like wavered on ever
trying to continuously do everything to
to continue to make our relationship
better and better and put our lives at
the Forefront of everything in our when
we had kids put the kids at the front
like every continue with kids to put our
relationship at the front and you know
not only have a movie tonight and a
breakfast date tomorrow and uh Friday
night uh pasta and Saturday with the
kids and karate and going to the fair
and then uh martial arts with the kids
on Sunday and going to the movie again
like it's just my whole life is is built
around keeping our family and home and
relationship at the highest level and
part of that is like
um qualitatively asking her having a
conversation every day how she feels
um about
the relationship and yesterday I got a
three yesterday I got three you know
what I mean and like I it's still like a
conversation and I know like it was
because I shot that day then I had these
you know some a couple of heavy big
business meetings that are business
calls that were more ad hoc than part of
the Rhythm right because every day I
send her my schedule of what I'm doing
that entire day with a love quote so she
has complete visibility on what my day
flow is and where where we will spend
time together and then ultimately
um
so I don't choose something over her I.E
when we're supposed to be watching a
show together and then I go do this call
for 30 minutes uh because I have to gets
me a three you know but I'm you know
deeply aware that I'm I'm treading on
disrupting the flow of what it is but
you know it's it's I've trailed off into
how we how I support that relationship
but again it's a beautiful beginning but
ultimately you know you don't have an
extraordinary relationship and an
amazing family and home by just doing it
in between all of the other stuff you do
like you have to design it with
intention and then you have to
continually optimize it because you're
changing your wife's changing your kids
are changing your needs are changing all
of this stuff is is moving and evolving
on this continuous basis so you have to
continually be setting and resetting and
optimizing it towards energy right
because that you just want that high
energy in your house between you and
your spouse the people you work with
every interaction that you have that's
really what you're chasing and on all
levels of your life that requires a
continual assessment and optimization
because everything is changing always
how did you get your wife to buy into
this very
optimized objective metrics of a
relationship process was there ever any
issues with trying to get this so
operationalized well I I think she sees
the benefits of it right like especially
the rhythm of existence and how we even
run our household with and how we you
know each week we have a family sink
with all the assistance and everything
and the rhythm of the house and how we
Run Grocery systems in here and and just
sort of the you know first it was two
dates a week and then that wasn't enough
like she felt like and she's seen the
system like slowly get optimized to
where she's happier and and feeling more
loved and feeling feeling that energy
and balance in herself so she's just
seen the output of it and and and now
the belief has been built right and and
think about it you don't necessarily
have I'm not asking her to hey send me
your rating today
we have a conversation about it right so
so it's like I used to try all different
types of things of of asking her and and
then I I would email and email me any
notes like then it's like I don't want
to email you then it was like then it
was a it was really funny like one year
it was like I we we started the
conversation and then she would feel
that like it's been a bad streak for
like two weeks and I'd be like no it's
actually only been like three days it
feels like two weeks and then she would
be like that Dad is like you skewed the
data you know what I mean like you know
it was like and so then I had to like
then send an email of the number so that
it was validated so that like you so
that there was no even more independent
record of what happened that's it and so
you know to me all that did was continue
to build belief in the system but when
you think about the beauty of
qualitative data it's just it's just a
higher level of awareness this because
you've got to you've got to spend the
time to reflect and ask yourself how you
feel about anything in order to pull the
insights that you need in order to make
it better and evolve it right because if
you just hope it happens naturally
you're never going to guide it or
control it you want to control your
evolution in in every part of you and
every relationship and everything in
your life is evolving and that's where
just asking yourself and using that
qualitative awareness allows you to
reflect because you have to reflect in
order to even assess something to decide
what should I change or evolve to even
make it better right and most people
forget about like being disciplined to
work out or eat right now you haven't
worked out for a week you feel terrible
you you look at yourself in the middle
you're mad at yourself so you have a
glass of wine because you had a long
crazy day and end up binging Netflix
till 10 30 then get a bad night sleep
then wake up late now and now I gotta
get all this stuff done it's like you're
just fighting through all of that uh let
alone trying to get to some reflective
Insight that's going to evolve you and
make you better you never even take the
time to be like okay what can I do to
get out of this rut you know what I mean
what what can I change in my overall
life that has to be the core operating
uh sort of piece of your flow in order
to continually and rapidly get better
and better at becoming the ideal version
of yourself
have you ever felt like you're
connected or you experience your life
but you're not connected to it like you
sort of things are happening and they're
washing over you and you're an active
participant but you're also kind of
passive like things don't really
they don't connect with you on the way
that they should it's something that I'm
seeing a lot more people talk about on
the internet and there's this sort of
culture of cynicism that become very
intimately familiar with and I I tweeted
about
how pissed off I was yesterday uh
basically saying that I'm sick of all of
these people who see hope as the problem
and that there is a culture of cynicism
on the internet that I absolutely hate
so I wanted to start a toxic positivity
movement and um
um
it seems to me that you're incredibly
connected to your life it it makes sense
because if you do anything with
intention the outcomes end up being very
aligned with what you intended to happen
presuming that they don't get perturbed
on the way and after all of these
iterations what you intend to happen is
often what does happen you're also
afforded this by having you know more
resources and and a team around you that
can help it to happen
but there is still a big chunk of people
out there for whom experiences in their
life happen but they don't feel
connected to them what would you say to
those people that are feeling a little
bit detached
yeah look I I I'm I can't relate right
because think about like I love my life
at a deep deep level I I am in awe of my
life you know what I mean like I
continuously like like I don't practice
gratitude I'm overwhelmed by it like
I'll be in my shower and be like look at
this life you have this is like nuts
that you get to do this like even the
chaos yesterday these big like ad hoc
business calls it's like look at this
look at how crazy your life is that you
get to like pull these levers how fun is
this right it's the the disconnection
and life as a whole is when like you
there's zero intention right and then if
you have zero intention then you don't
like anything that that you have in your
life you don't like your job like you
you your friends you you know you end up
talking about how your friends are so
toxic you have one good friend that you
basically uh don't let you can confide
in all the hate you want to share with
all your other friends like you just end
up in this world where but every now and
again you have a pocket of motivation
you try to be healthy for a bit you try
to do this for a bit like and and you
can't help but feel hopeless
right and then like God forbid you begin
to build a case of the world being
against you and and then think of think
about the mindset of and the way that
the mind works you know because again
you're you're in in an action State
you're experiencing the present you're
enjoying the present you can only really
judge how you feel about anything in the
present moment and it's Purity it's like
you're either then creating a a better
future and excited about what the
possibilities or you go past that and
you're worrying about the future
right and then like you go the other way
that's the past and then it's like okay
something happened and you're just
dealing with it and handling it and
getting it done or you're you're pushing
all the way back down now to worry and
and again people that are hopeless live
in what I like to consider the sorrow
triangle right where you are just
swinging between
like reactive and inactive and worrying
and dwelling right so you're just
constantly blaming the past or wishing
this or worrying about the future not
becoming but you're sitting in this
state where you're dealing with
everything as it comes or doing nothing
there's zero Pro activity in creating a
better future designing a better future
and going through the process that it
takes to get there and again you're
you're basically a system of systems
that all integrate together that
naturally uh go into an intuitive
subconscious state and if you have a bad
system that just keeps you in this state
it's almost impossible to get out and
then you think man if I just got in the
relationship that would get me out then
you get in the relationship and it's
you're just it's chaos and adds a new
level of chaos to you then it's like man
if I could just get this job then the
job isn't what you thought you always
think you're one thing away man if I go
to this uh Tony Robbins seminar that's
going to be what does it you know if you
get some motivation in you you're just
looking for one thing and and again I I
believe this as an absolute truth that
you can't change one part of you without
changing all of you
like you have to you have to take a look
at all of you and design with intention
the whole if you ever want to get there
but I do believe as it relates to being
uh emotionally affected by this group of
the internet that lives in this constant
state of you know
bitterness if you will
and they could literally they could you
know they could pick apart anything that
there possibly is you know what I mean
it's like I don't believe that there's
so much depth and dysfunction in the
overall system that like they almost
only get energy from taking shots and
firing and getting a reaction it's
almost like they need to watch something
that fires them up and then they they
need to have a deep conversation about
how like the world's gonna fall apart
and like this is the beginning they've
they go they get that energy from this
deep negative sort of almost thought
experiments and contemplation right is
where their energy is derived from and
and that's what a toxic person is and
and it takes a depth a depth of
awareness to ever get there and I think
most people if there they're going to do
it do it much later in life where they
they settle down into like okay my
expectations are never going to be met
where am I at and what can I do to just
make it a little bit better I've seen
some of the most bitter friends I have
like get into
like you know what I'd call a mild
personal development right where they're
they're like people that hate all things
personal development and so they would
never like
call it that they'd just be like oh just
been like getting up or I've been
starting to work out you know just
adding little things to better
themselves like but they would never
like read a book on like you know like
how to build a life design or framework
or even like assess yourself they just
wouldn't even they would never bother
but seeing it sort of crack in and
seeing them get way happier but you're
47. you know what I mean it's like and
you're already like I can see your body
I can see like your mind and already see
that like you're going to be in sort of
this rhythm of hopelessness till the day
that you die and and you've seen many of
people uh go through it and what what
how do you ex how do you look at them I
just look at them as like man it's like
it's the the simulation is yours to
design and yours to ultimately
um learn to control and ultimately guide
it towards your one months and needs and
you either believe that or you believe
that the world is controlling you and
you have no choice so what's the use and
those of us that believe that they
actually have control and someone like
me who actually took complete control
and then now controls it almost uh
completely and now is guiding it and and
watching the magic happen and being in
awe of being able to experience it I
look at life as incredible I don't
contemplate a recession I don't
contemplate like uh what's going to
happen to uh the currency reserve of the
United States and how it's going to
affect me I know like whatever happens
in this world who's elected whatever it
is that sure it may affect some aspects
of my existence but not uh very little
because I've built so much defenses
around my quality of life and my
happiness that all no outside effect is
ever going to affect it do you think
that you would have the same mindset
without all of the money
it's it's
interesting right because I'm
you know I'm when I see like you know if
I you know post something related to
money and time and sort of how it all
works together usually for you with all
that money and I I think to myself
um maybe right maybe but money's
relative right in the sense of I've I've
been able to rapidly evolve and and
create a very big complex life that is
very effortless to operate and I've used
money to buy back time I used money to
um be able to scale what I'm able to do
Beyond Myself still limiting using a
limited amount of time but I don't think
it's money
um only would have got me here but I do
believe money design and growing money
is a Cornerstone of a high quality life
right because at the end of the day like
it's really will always be about how
much money you spend versus how much
money you earned uh versus the taxes you
paid and then how much you have saved
that balance right there is always going
to be where your peace of mind is
because you don't need hundreds of
millions like I have but if you have
um you know if you spend 50 Grand
instead of spending uh 80 grand a year
and end up now saving after 15 years and
have 800 Grand save and you're spending
50 well boy you're going to feel real
secure and if something happens you're
going to be like well you know I'm good
to go like until I got some time to
figure it out or now that I don't
necessarily need to
earn any more income I can go fly fish
or whatever it is that I really am
passionate wish that I could do because
make no mistake your ability to use your
time to do what you want will be dick
rotated on the amount of money you need
to live the life that you want to live
and so you can't have high expectations
on a lifestyle and and not have a clear
path to how to earn the money or a
strategy on where to invest that money
so that you eventually don't have to
continue to earn it you can live off the
money that you've earned and saved
that's now growing so that you can live
the life that you can make and if you
don't design that
you will never get there yet it is what
everybody needs to do in order to live a
high quality life and what are you going
to do right now well I'm going to work a
job I don't like and retire at 65 and
now it's 65 I finally get to do the
things that I want
you know what I mean and and that's like
sort of the worker construct that we've
put in sort of society that I would call
from the you know the World War era that
sort of has evolved over time and the
iteration of that is a better job at
college and better 401ks and different
and uh different investment tax
efficient Investments for retirees so
that when you get to 60 65 now you can
spend the time doing what you want to do
have you read die with zero
I have not no you would absolutely adore
it I'm not one for dishing Out book
advice
I'm not sure that I've I've come across
a book that is closer aligned with your
philosophy it's a guy called Bill
Perkins he's coming on the show in a
week and a bit I think his daughter
perhaps comes to UT so he's going to
come through town I'm going to record
with him I I believe that this book's
going to be one of these seminal
personal development books and it's
going to have a real long tail to it so
it'll be an atomic habit and the
obstacle is the way or whatever uh and
his his entire concept die with zero I
mean the book kind of says it itself
um and he talks about the memory
dividend about front loading particular
experiences there are certain
experiences you can only have at certain
periods of your life which means that it
is important for you to do it now
presuming that you're going to increase
your earning capacity over time most
people spend they underspend their
current earning potential what you
actually want to do is front load your
future earning potential to now when you
have more freedom more robustness in
your body more optionality more
availability because that's experience
allows you to then think about it and
you get a little titrated dose of the
memory that you had as opposed to if you
wait until you're 60 to try and go
skiing if you can go six if your knees
can take it when you're 60. you've spent
all of that time not paying yourself the
memory dividend so I think I think um a
lot of different people are converging
on the same idea which is this
slow life strategy which encourages
people to delay gratification because if
you delay gratification to the extreme
there's no gratification right right and
yet we've uploaded this
you know marshmallow test world and and
quite rightly so because willpower and
conscientiousness and industriousness
their predictors of success and the
things that people rely on but we take
the
philosophy that we use to be successful
in business
and we then try and apply it to fun in
our lives they go no like that I don't I
don't think that necessarily those are
things that should be mapped on to each
other I don't think that not
spending time having fun outside of work
makes you more effective or more
virtuous when it comes to your success
within work I don't think that that's
the way it should it should operate but
but again I don't I still look at that
as a little bit too binary now you're
saying don't do it when you're old do it
now right and to me it's like like
no do it with intention do it with an
understanding do it with purpose right
do it today and every day for the rest
of your life
right there there is no do it now while
you can so you don't have to do it later
do do it all right but you've got to do
it with intention and if you don't learn
money and understand money it's like
you're what are you going to do you're
gonna like oh I'll spend it all now
because I can make it later because like
I can't ski because I'm going to be on
that ski trip but well if you understood
money and understood that like well no
actually if I do half of it now like and
and and and work harder for two years
and invest that I can actually ski in
one month of the year for the rest of my
life that's it right so like to me and
again I don't
what I prescribe to is you don't ever
want to get somewhere you want to be
there always right and and when it comes
to money you just want to create a
system that you understand and believe
in that over time when it it will grow
into giving you more security peace of
mind and ability to use your time
differently to do more of what you'd
like to do but don't
try to get to a place where you're not
sacrificing to get there right where
you're doing it from a harmonious way
and that you're enjoying life while
still planning and preparing for a
better future a better tomorrow
and perhaps sometimes you sacrifice to
accelerate that and sometimes it ends up
being Oh I thought I'd be able to save
that money in 20 years and now it's 30
years or in other cases man if I just
really focus on this company I can sell
this thing in two years and then now
invest into my plan and be able to do
whatever I want for the next 15 years
right there's it's having the clarity
about money nobody ever seeks
right it's just what do you need to
spend how much do you earn
and how much of that do you need to to
to invest in where do you want to invest
it it's just pick a lane make an index
fund that's 10 and it doubles every
seven years cool you know what I mean
pick a lane for me that's why I just
picked like syndicated multi-family real
estate because I loved it because it's
like you get cash and it's tax-free okay
let's do it right and I had zero you
know I had zero and and then I just
started adding one at a time and then
when I sold the first company I didn't
what was I going to do with the money I
didn't like oh should I could get a
diverse like portfolio of equities and
like oh no I put it all into the
strategy one strategy right and then
when I got to you know over 50 million
in just those buildings and now like my
way of living
is now never going to be compromised I
get to fly private live in a house have
Ferraris live this life for the rest of
my life what's no matter what what's the
cash earning from 50 million ish of
those properties it's it ends up Blended
at about seven percent right so you know
you're you're talking about about three
and a half million at fifty right and
that's tax-free dollars right is that
substitutional to an LLC
that's too personal right so yeah yeah
so you don't like I don't there's no
need to run it through uh a vehicle
because you basically all if you owned
it 100 it would just pass through to you
anyway and and you get the depreciation
because you're an owner of the building
so that entire you know three and a half
million is tax free right and so and so
you know when when I got to 30 million I
started in in uh and my first investment
was a hundred grand my second investment
was like you know 150 you know and when
I got to 30 million I was like I could
man I could be done right now this is
kind of it was this amazing feel and
what did I do I just got more motivated
so now like I get to that level now I've
sold a couple companies now I got to 30
in my real estate play like I'm you
begin to see all this stuff coming
together now I'm designing my time and
more harmoniously I'm using the
qualitative data I'm I'm getting happier
I'm getting more disciplined you see
where all of it is getting more
integrated and all of it is getting
better together and all of it is serving
the whole which is then making me better
and better keeping me more and more
motivated against the idea of like man I
can just keep becoming better and better
and better in all aspects of life and
then it goes to 50 million 75 million
100 million now it's like man everything
I will ever want to do in my life is
covered uh by this cash right like but
what happens along the way I sign a
billion dollar television deal and end
up uh you know shooting 336 episodes of
television in 2013 when I was like
offered that 360 deal I hated shooting
television
and shooting 40 episodes of
Ridiculousness a year I despised because
it would take me all day to shoot it and
I would shoot for a month straight five
days a week and it would drive me insane
like I hated everything about it but
then I began to optimize the shooting
began to spread the schedule out began
to vote like I if I didn't optimize it
to that level I would have never even
been able to sign an episode deal to
shoot 336. it wouldn't even have been
possible even in 2017 or 18 you know and
and so you you begin to see how all of
this stuff together
it allowed everything to get better and
better more efficient you learn it
better you you keep making everything
better because I would not have been
able to uh shoot the 308 episodes a day
if I hadn't got as healthy as I've
gotten
and and then gotten so disciplined and
being like being so consistent all that
you begin to see how all of it ladders
together and then the freedom that I
have you know I've been working on my
philosophy in my book I paid a writer up
front two years ago to just begin to
ideate for two years I'm paying five
million dollars to develop the software
just to do it I have an entire you know
marketing team that cost me a couple
million a year that I'm just building
out my entire philosophy and this
software and all of this together to be
more of my legacy piece but I've been
doing it for years and I'm able to
invest in it with by myself with not
even no concerns of a timeline no
concern no Stakes on whether or not it
even works I get to just continually
evolve and optimize it as I'm evolving
and sharpen it and sharpen it with the
intent of like create something special
that impacts your world impacts your
your children and ultimately something
that creates a legacy and and what
people really know you for helping them
see themselves in a holistic Manner and
design their whole with intention Master
time and energy and live a truly happy
life you know
it's in Spider-Man it really really is
to see somebody Wrangle reality and
distort it around them to turn it into
what it is that they wanted it's very
very inspiring when I mean it sounds
like you're just in the process without
any Rush
is there any idea when people are going
to be able to get their hands on the
book on the software or on anything else
is there any sort of a schedule for this
uh you know I don't I don't I haven't
like locked into a hard date you know I
think for me as it relates to really big
projects especially when you have a lot
of freedom with them
um and you need to sort of trial an
error and grow into it let it show
itself to you
um that's sort of the patience that I've
been been doing with this and
essentially let it show itself then lock
in to the Hard dates and goals to bring
it alive and I think I'm probably going
to be ready to do that towards the end
of this year which really puts me
because I want to kind of do it all
together you know because really you
know the real ecosystem of everything
because it's gonna be it's gonna be all
the content like a couple like movies
and documentaries like the book itself
and then this all of which will be the
top of funnel for the software right and
so it's a it's a there's a lot of
complexity as it relates to how to roll
all of that out an effective way but at
the core there most important thing is
the philosophy that will be captured in
the book is the most important right and
that's the Legacy piece and that's
basically the anchor to it all and so
being incredibly patient with that is is
really where I'm at because again when I
when I put it on my vision board uh you
know in January of 2020 when I
conceptualized it decided to write the
concept and begin the process which had
me go through a couple writing people
even the beginnings I had to find
somebody that understood the philosophy
to help me evolve it right and like I'm
I saw a a photo of Rick Ross who posted
like the boss New York Times bestseller
the boss right and I'm like and I I
swiped through and looked at the list
right and it was the boss and number two
was like I don't know it was like number
one was Atomic habits and I I looked it
there and it said like 500 in like 70
weeks and then it was like
um you are a badass like like 500 and
like you know 12 whatever it was it was
like multiple years on it yeah and then
like I realized at that point like hey
no you are you are creating a work that
needs to be on par with having the
ability to live
um in the New York Times for five plus
years right and on my vision board I
Photoshopped it in at number one right
underneath like I think atlas of the
heart of brene brown and I put like 872
weeks at on the charts right like that's
how specific I got on my vision board of
what my intention was even creating the
concept you know and and again I when I
look at it
um I want it to I want to know that it
is deeply sound and you got to think
about like a deep philosophy is
Simplicity on the far side of complexity
and so you have to be able to distill it
down to where it's deeply and easily
understandable by the masses and that it
grows complex and is appealing to a
complex mind like yourself in its depth
uh in order to reach the the same level
that something like Atomic habits did
you know I'm just having a little look
I've done at Google there the longest
duration on the New York Times
bestseller list founded in 1935 is for
The Road Less Traveled by Scott Peck
which on the 14th of April 1995 had its
598th week on the list over 5 million
copies of the book and then there's
another one here that suggests the Diary
of a Wimpy Kid I think is also a monster
600 and
three
listen listen
to me I photoshopped a new on my vision
board I photoshopped from my library of
a Wimpy Kid you know what I'm saying but
what like think about that and it's like
870 weeks I've I have picked a number an
arbitrary number that was bigger than
Atomic habits and you are a badass to be
like this is the goal right and so think
about think about what that how that
changes your approach rather than you
know traditionally someone with a
mainstream Fame whose reality TV in a
big television show like what do they
make a book for it's like to get a
million dollar advance and like you know
tell your story you know what I mean
like it's the it's the intent that you
even put into Big Ideas and then the
patience with purpose to allow that idea
to evolve and reveal itself to you and
and and be able to know that you're
You're Building depth in something and
and Trust the process and be willing
where the resources come in is pay for
that process right that's what I'm using
the my my uh ability to generate cash
flow for to be able to push forward a
much bigger more depth higher level
higher quality product and project uh
because I have the patience and
understanding of what it takes to
actually create something great and am
willing to put in the time and the
effort even if it pushes out to 2025.
you know what I mean because I'll be
Sprite and young and feeling better than
ever in my mid 50s you know what I mean
hell yeah Rob Dyrdek ladies and
gentlemen dudes I find you very very
inspirational I like the fact that
there's this intentional life I think
it's something that is an answer to a
lot of people's problems at the moment
uh there's this interesting story from
Aristotle and he he talks about a man
who is going to leave his house on the
morning and if you were to ask him where
he was going to go he would say they he
wasn't sure he was maybe going to see
some people and do some things and that
person is going to be blown around
through life like a cork bobbing in the
ocean and he'll move but he won't go on
a journey and I think that the
difference between being a cork bobbing
on the ocean and being a man that goes
out to sea and has adventures and and
decides to use winds and waves to direct
himself is a very very important one so
if the people that are listening want to
keep up to date with any of the stuff
that you do and find out when the book
and the optimization and all of that
stuff is released where should they go
uh yeah everything is Rob Dyrdek
robdyrdek.com Rob Dyrdek social Rob
Dyrdek everything you know I was early
on you know had that name got it got it
early on in the brand name everything's
Rob Dyrdek you know good stuff Rob I
appreciate you thank you yeah thank you
for having me really enjoyed it what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace